Clearing debris from the old hut
The old ropes are rotting
So we must remove them and start from scratch for safety
Making a game plan for rebuilding the hut
removing the old, weak posts
Picking the right tree is important
This is Jake's favorite part
Cutting logs for the perimeter fence
Timber!
Taking breaks is important
There is lots to do, so we split up the tasks
Jarrett builds the fence
Jake works on the walls
While Nick collects roofing materials
Conversation makes working fun
Jake is digging a fire pit
Nick is making small ropes, because we ran out of lashing rope
Can't have a fire pit without some rocks
spreading some dirt around because why not
Praying to Chungus to keep the rains away from our village
Can't stress enough the importance of this step
The dirt must be raked
Making a spit for the fire pit
these logs are very heavy
and very far away
teamwork must be used to retrieve these logs
the nettles, they sting
remember to subscribe
Jake works on carving logs for a throne
Jarrett puts finishing touches on the hut
Nick goes out to search for a stone to make an axe head
This stick will be an axe soon
it looks like an axe..
..but does it cut like one?